let's jump to this story from fox
business
californians warned of possible rolling
blackouts as state battles historic
heatwave perhaps the collapse you know
for those who are just joining away the
segment where this lady was saying if
civil war happened she wouldn't last a
week maybe she would maybe last two no
guns no bunkers no food perhaps it won't
be a civil war they have to worry about
perhaps it's just going to be rolling
blackouts i saw a video i think it was
out of italy where they're they're
they're going to school and working by
candlelight yeah yeah because the energy
costs are so high
so um well and you're starting to see
that even here in america where people
you know affordability of just your
basic utilities has gone up double if
not triple in some areas and i mean this
is impacting every single american it's
insane and you know i'm going to defer
to the energy expert here but i mean i
put a lot of this on the fact that we
have sustainable energy sources at our
disposal under our feet and they
continue to go to unreliable renewables
which we saw texas even try at one point
with their you know wind turbines and
they're now
you know regretting that decision i mean
we have to get back to energy
independence but we can do that through
the actual energy sources that are
reliable energy sources like coal and
gas and oil the things that are under
our feet nuclear nuclear as well
absolutely but look in california they
can't
they've they've
culted themselves into a corner they've
told everybody we can't do it because
nuclear is bad and climate change
i'll tell you this right now
i don't care what your position is on
climate change california objectively
screwed themselves energy wise because
when you come out and say
carbon is bad and and burning all this
fossil fuels is making the climate worse
the response is okay nuclear is a good
option right totally green and it's got
an excellent energy return on energy
invested no no nuclear is bad as well
because nuclear is dirty three-mile
island
that's what everyone just says with
nuclear fukushima
and then and then the response is okay
go for wind i guess
good luck and now you get
rolling they're they're saying it's like
a stage two emergency in california
they can't build nuclear because they
campaigned on hating it they can't build
new uh you know fossil fuel plants they
campaigned on hating it and they don't
have the battery power for wind or solar
when margery taylor green criticized i
think it was uh solar power
saying that when the sun goes down you
lose the power i like having the lights
on at night everyone laughed liberals
mocked her they're like oh you're so
dumb dude large scale
solar systems there's not batteries for
this solar works really really well
during the day when you have the energy
and it has to be supplemented at night
with fossil fuels or nuclear salts kind
of i'll defer to you daniel you know
better than i do molten salt you
familiar with the molten salt reactors
no i mean molten salt blue hydrogen
there's lots of great things in theory
that i think
i would be fine seeing investors not the
government i would find
seeing them develop and if they work
it's great i welcome all technologies
but the problem is the electric grid is
for good or for ill it is run by the
state
right and and if the state is in charge
of giving you electricity then the state
has a responsibility to give you damn
electricity and the state is failing its
job they don't even know what
electricity is no they have no idea hold
on most people don't no and that's okay
but if you're coming out and talking
about energy policy and you don't know
anything about it and i'm not going to
pretend to be an expert on this by any
stretch of the imagination but it's
fascinating me i was talking to someone
a long time ago and i said do you know
where electricity comes from and they
went the wall yeah there you go and i
said yeah yeah but like where if i was
like you plug it in the wall it's there
and i was like okay there's like cables
back there right and they're like i
guess you think it's by design where
where does the electricity come from in
that thing and they're like
i don't know
they don't know now to be fair well
that's because they don't know the
history of westinghouse and all the rest
i mean but but so the fascinating thing
is what they don't understand is that
it's it's a flow it's a circuit it has
to keep going the reason they shut down
parts is because it's overloaded and it
can't complete a circuit
so you ask people what the fascinating
thing about energy is that it's all
basically steam power right even nuclear
power it's boiling water to create steam
pressure to spin a turbine it's kinetic
energy yeah kinetic energy large
rotating magnets to create electrical
current which then the current flows
through the grid
they don't understand why we can't have
wind and solar be like our permanent
solutions yeah and it's one of the great
evils that the green movement does
is that you take an a coal power plant
that creates uh 900 megawatts of coal
power you take a natural gas power plant
same idea nuclear plant 4 000 megawatts
of power right they will say well if we
build 4 000 acres of solar we'll get the
same capacity it's like but there's a
huge variable that means it has to
consistently shine the sun
non-stop with no cloud cover with no
that is a variable or
massive acreages of underground
batteries
which is insane which is not possible
and not not to mention who does this
actually benefit you know this whole
idea the green new deal or these
renewable energy sources only promotes
china economics i mean they control 15
of the 16 rare mineral mines in the
world they are where we're going to get
a lot of our solar you know panels and
all these different things with a
lithium that's necessary especially as
joe biden in the botched afghan
withdrawal just gave 1.2 trillion
dollars in
lithium mines from afghanistan to the
chinese so the whole life point is is
that why are we continuing to promote
and benefit
our adversarial nations and dependency
upon them as opposed to getting back to
energy independence here in america and
going back to an america first agenda
which is where we need to be as a nation
if they were just honest
you know uh yeah
i'd say okay if they came out and said
oh yeah we know 60 million people will
die overnight when we enact this policy
i'd be like well at least they're
telling you what they're doing and if
you vote for at least you know what
you're voting for but but a lot of
people who are listening to these insane
policies don't know that they're voting
for their way of life to be done yeah
and so so we saw this in denver
people couldn't change their thermostats
you saw that one it's unbelievable they
they 22 000 people they opted in though
yes that's what they said so so here's
how it goes because this is actually
what happened it's going to happen more
and more when you sign up for your
electric company or whatever
they say would you like to sign up for
our energy saver program it's a hundred
dollars off your bill per year they go
wow a hundred dollars off per year i'll
sign up for energy say they don't read
it then one day it's 99 degrees outside
and the thermostat says energy saver
mode activated and you can't change it
and they say why can't i change my
thermostat and say well you opted in
maybe you should opt out but we gave you
a free we gave you a cheap deal because
you were willing to do this
so that's that's that's the bit that i
um
i did on twitter where i said absolutely
right i saw that you're 100 right it's
99 degrees you go to set your thermostat
with your locked out governor's orders
he declared an emergency so he decided
you know what i'll go take a drive you
go to your electric vehicle but the
screen says no charge available car
wasn't charging sorry governor's orders
governors so he decided to walk down to
the park and just go and get some fresh
air but the checkpoint down there
that the tweet was limited but there's a
guy saying sir if you want to work past
me you've got to scan your care code on
your phone and you're like i can't my
phone's dead i can't use the electricity
i'm sorry sir with no qr code then they
tase you because that's where the
electricity goes then you go home back
to your pod where you grab a bag of
crickets to snack on and wait for the
temperature to go down yeah i think that
that is the future you joke but that is
the future this
if the democrats
and the liberals continue in the path
that they're trying to which is
destroying us economically politically
militarily that's actually a real life
scenario that could occur yeah look at
california right now robbing blackouts i
can't say this with any more sincerity
and i know people can think i'm crazy it
is a huge mistake to buy any sort of
smart thermostat a nest any of those
things
if you need if you're like i need to be
able to control with my phone then then
have a kid and tell the kid go go lower
the thermos
that's why god invented children
this is like the old days when you'd be
like all right i need to change the
television channel go up there
i uh
buy mechanical cars
yeah so you know because i have a tesla
and everybody's like asking me like you
really bought one of those things like
why
and i'm like well you know it's electric
car i wanted to have it as an option and
they're like yeah but you realize we're
getting close to the point where like in
california they ordered people not to
know
still i believe right now they can't
charge their cars yeah so what do you do
you can't
look they have these cars i think this
is where i go back to sustainability
right i mean i have a generac generator
at home and but in both of our houses we
have a generic generator just in case i
do have a solar backup just in case but
not on my roof what i use it for is i've
got these kind of lithium ion like
storage uh that i can actually utilize
solar to charge off of it it's for
traveling you know when my family goes
camping or we go out for a sustained
period of time etc but these are areas
that i can you know it tells me i have
this much time i could run my
refrigerator off of it this much this
many times i can charge a computer or a
phone or etc and obviously you can kind
of do it to wherever you want but my
whole point is is that i don't utilize
that as my idea of a main source of
energy i utilize it as a backup source
of energy just in the event of a storm
or things like this so i've called for
whistleblowers i'll do it again
the left you have to admire their
solidarity with each other right there
aren't a lot of whistleblowers there's
no alyssa farah whatever the former
trump spokeswoman who's now on the view
who's just on a tirade about how much
she hates trump most disloyal benedict
arnold etc but the left doesn't do that
but i will renew my call for a
whistleblower so i'd love to know what
the governor mansion in california is
right now i'd love to know if paul
pelosi is charging his electric pours
i'd love to know if dianne feinstein's
house is literally set at 79. because
that is the orders and the end the
answer is of course they're not none of
their offices are set at below 79. none
of them have off unnecessary lights but
we saw the same thing though with
governor whitmer right we saw it in
michigan whenever nobody's allowed to
take their boats out her husband's
allowed to again this is that two-tiered
elitist justice system that i talk about
that i can't stand that we have to break
the mold on where political elitists and
celebrities can act with impunity and
the rest of americans basically get
tossed under the bus but if you thought
it was that angering that you were in
lockdown and nancy pelosi was able to
get her hair cut or you were in lockdown
and the governor of michigan michelle
lujan grisham opened up a store for her
personality that's not expected
no but if that upsets you that that that
that hypocrisy just wait until the end
upsets me hang on hang on wait until the
energy hypocrisy kicks in that you are
not allowed to use electricity today but
the governor's mansion is totally lit up
you are not allowed to charge it on
tesla but i can charge mine why well
because i'm the senior senator from
california but this is the same idea and
hypocrisy is going to this hypocrisy
though is exactly what frustrates me
about politicians because
we actually will hold your feet over the
fire if you're doing or committing
insider trading but yet we're allowing
politicians their wives and their
offices to buy sell and trade stocks
that they know they're going to pass
legislation on they know they're going
to directly manipulate why has that not
been cut off by the left or the right
this isn't even a republican verse
democrat or a socialist first communist
you know or communist situation this
this is literally just a right versus
wrong a good versus bad the left
populous and the right populist degree
on that point that's the establishment
politicians who are like no no no no
you're not taking away our insider i did
really well last year my portfolio was
fantastic only because of my you know my
my top secret security clearance and
then the skiff
and the fact that i know what
legislation is getting right i mean
imagine deep diving and who bought
pfizer moderna and johnson and johnson
before they made this decision imagine
looking at the ideas of this renewable
energy and who's bought into tesla and
all the others my point is is that just
like we need to stop a two-tiered
justice system we need to stop the
insider trading and the fact that our
politicians and our celebrities are able
to act in a way that the rest of america
doesn't and we are the majority as
american the funny thing about faiza
moderna was that weird speech that biden
gave yesterday where he was screaming i
beat pharma i beat pharma and he's
yelling and you're like beat pharma have
you seen their profits this year
pfizer was like please please lord beat
me again beat me harder daddy like i
beat pharma oh my gosh modern and pfizer
had had a great what did he mean when he
was saying that no one knows what he
would what does he what happened
what
just a general question what does he
mean and i was thinking on the way over
we're getting to the campaign season
that useless politicians and that does
not include you because you're not a
politician i'm never going to be a
politician the useless politicians will
start saying all these things like i've
stood up to special interests and i've
taken on the big guys and i've fought
for kids and like all these vagaries and
that's what you'll buy in this whole
speech i've i took on pharma and i beat
pharma what the hell does that mean and
no one will ask let me know when you
think
you know when you talk about not taking
special interest groups when you talk
about taking on big pharma when you talk
about holding adversaries accountable
when you talk about proper foreign
policy and a more american first agenda
you can get as mad as you want
about his tweets but no one did greater
than president donald trump can you
really take on farmer though if you
haven't screamed it from a podium he
just gave us with a weird red backdrop
behind you he just gave us fi he gave
fiser like a blank check that's exactly
right but how is that doing good against
pharma that's what come on he's lying we
get it
no no biden but i'm talking about you
said donald trump was the best to take
in on big pharma but he gave pfizer a
blank check during the pandemic he also
didn't well he actually just helped to
do the research for i mean the blank
check if anything was on operation warp
speed which is just trying to get a
vaccination in play but what i'm talking
about is when he started actually
holding the pharmaceutical companies
accountable and saying that why is it
that all these other nations pay a half
or a third of the price of america when
we're one of the largest consumers we
need the lowest drug rates we need the
lowest drug prices we need to you know
go after what farm is doing by abusing
their rights here in america just
because we can afford to pay more
doesn't mean that we should pay more
that's holding them accountable did he
open up competition for 20 medicines
coming from you know canada canada yeah
correct and uh
for some reason and generic brands and
all right i've got they they hated him
they flipped out and they demanded that
he be removed and now you get big big
business biden and his illicit dealings
to come back in it's it's remarkable for
the big guy i've got to know about
electricity we before we move on to the
next story because we're talking about
currency and i think electricity is
going to be a currency of the future how
you transport energy is everything yeah
electrical currency it's an actual
phrase um
so like you were saying people don't
know what electricity is a lot of people
why that's by design because we didn't
teach kids in school how to make an
electrical current that's probably by
design too because if you give people
the power to create their own
electricity you lose control of them so
the government's in a position now where
they're like what do we do are we going
to give people the power or are we going
to try and hold on to it as society
falls around us and if people did have
the power and everyone in the world had
equal power to the government would it
just be a constant state of evolution
and fighting and destroying and the
strong man comes up with the with the
techno so like is it good that people
don't have that power we've all seen you
know on youtube perpetual motion yeah
all those videos where people uh build
perpetual motion machines and generate
free electricity like that proves it at
face value i'd love everyone has their
own nuclear everyone has their own power
generator everyone has infinite but what
would it would be until the strong man's
like i'm going to use my power to
destroy that guy and take his so i have
twice as much like
that's the history of humanity is this
that's the strong so is the government
doing the right thing by keeping people
stupid and subservient what it would the
people would it be constant war if they
didn't no i can understand your point of
saying if if the government supplies the
electricity maybe we take away that
potential for conflict between
households or neighborhoods or whatever
and i can understand that but then if
we've given the government that that
power then they also have that
responsibility and they're failing that
responsibility you know a great radio
host who i'm friends with and i go on a
show a lot of jessie kelly out of
houston he was replying on a bunch of
tweet threads saying you don't get to
ask me to reduce my electricity
consumption because your job is not to
tell me how to live my life your job is
to produce electricity and if you're the
governor of california and it is a
numbers game california has to generate
i think it's like something like 52 000
uh megawatts of electricity a day if you
don't produce that then you're failing
your people and that's all the election
matters about you can talk about the
election it's about equity it's about
justice it's about creating a more
tolerant society for california it's
about homeless all that is crap so the
government the election in california
should be on based on the fact that as
governor you are responsible for a few
things crime and boy are you failing
electricity production boy are you
failing and gavin newsom will win
re-election
effortlessly because that is also the
two-tier system that we're dividing into
when one last thing just to finish when
california as tim said they have to
start to shut down segments of the grid
to keep the overall sustainability when
they shut down areas look who they shut
down it will not be silicon valley it
will not be facebook's office it will
not be a kardashian household or malibu
it'll be middle and low-income families
voiceless powerless people who have
useless republicans representing them in
congress will get pledged into darkness
and they'll be like this is unfair but
if you live in the central valley and
you go four days without power you pray
to god your congressman fights for you
but obviously your congressman is
probably just going to be like well you
know life sucks guys but i was in dc i
witnessed this personally during the
drought in uh i think it was like 2015 i
went to larry county
poor working families had had no water
golf courses did yeah the city
you know the people with money they want
no no don't get me wrong it's like they
were doing well they were in a serious
drought they had a lot of water but they
they got the water they needed and
that's that's the reality of it new york
where the power went out what was the
first neighborhood brownsville
which is an all-black neighborhood in
brooklyn uh summer of 2021 last year
when they had to turn off a small
percentage of the grid and bill de
blasio's administration and that's what
brownsville and east new york and if you
look at videos of that time the
residents there poor black people are
standing outside because you can't be
inside because the windows don't open in
those housing units but isn't it funny
that these are the exact same people who
say that you owe me your vote even
though i i put you always at the end of
the line you're the one this is why you
talked about earlier at the end of the
day the republican party went from being
the wine and cheese party to the beer
and blue jeans party and that happened
on a donald trump that happened with
president trump and whereas we have to
acknowledge that we now represent the
interests of the people we we now
represent the interest of the everyday
blue collar modern day society because
why most of us came from that like
myself my grandfather was a welder my
grandmother was a beautician they
adopted me because i lived in a you know
family where my mom and dad had
substance and drug abuse issues were in
and out of prison my entire life and
guess what that's why i fight so hard
for the american people because i am one
of you thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there